you're thinking about buying a house but
you really want to figure out how much
area does the house cover what is the
the square footage of the house or what
is the area of the foundation of the
house so right here we have the floor
plan of the house and you're tasked with
finding its area and you're given the
dimensions of a bunch of walls of the
house this wall right here is 18 feet
this is eight feet this is 20 feet 20
feet 5 feet 26 feet 15 feet and 25 feet
but you're a little confused you know
how to find the area of rectangles but
how do you find an area of a strain
shape like this so i encourage you to
pause this video and try to figure out
the area of this strange house
footprints shape floor plan shape using
the techniques that you already know
about
so what you already do know about is how
to find the area of rectangles so if we
can break this house's floor plan into a
series of rectangles and find out the
areas of those rectangles then we can
figure out the area of this entire house
so let's break it into a bunch of
simpler rectangles so i could have one
rectangle here it has a width of 20 feet
and it has a length of 20 feet so that
would be a rectangle
right over there we should be able to
figure out its area
then i could set up another rectangle
that has a width of 26 feet
and has a
length
that's its length right over there and
we could think about in a second what
that length actually is actually let's
think about that how would we figure out
what this length actually is
well this this length plus 5 feet is
going to be the same thing as this
length over here is the same as the
opposite wall of this of this rectangle
so this length plus 5 feet is 20 feet
well this must be
15 feet so this blue rectangle is 15
feet long and 26 feet wide
now let's add another rectangle we could
have one that's 18 feet long
and then goes the entire length of the
house
goes the entire length of the house like
that and you might say wait how do we
figure out its width how do we figure
out the width of this rectangle well we
know that this is 8 feet we know that
this is 20 feet and we know that this is
26 feet so the entire width is going to
be 26 feet plus 20 feet so 26 plus 20
gets us to 46
plus eight
gets us to 54 feet so this is 54
54
feet right over here did i do that right
let's see 8 plus 36 would be 34 plus 20
is 54 feet and then finally we have one
last rectangle to deal with this
rectangle right over here which is 15
feet long
and 25
and 25 feet
wide and so now we can calculate the
areas of the different rectangles so the
total area is going to be the 20 feet by
the 20 feet so let's just multiply them
so it's going to be 20
times 20. that's this area
right over here
plus 15 times 26
so plus
15 times 26
that's this area
right over there
plus
18 times 54 plus 18 times 54
which is this area
right over there
and then finally
plus 15 times 25
plus 15
times 25
which is
this area
this area
right over here so we just have to now
evaluate these things so what is 20
times 20 well this is going to be 400
what's 15 times 26 let's multiply it out
26
times 15
6 times 5 is 30
2 times 5 is 10 plus 3 is 13.
now i'm going to multiply a 10 times 26
gets us to 260
and you add these two together you get
390. so it's 400
plus 390.
now we've got to multiply 18 times 54 or
54 times 18. so let's do that 54 times
18.
eight times four is 32
8 times 5 is 40 plus 3 is 43.
now we're multiplying this 10 times 54
gets us to 540 and we add 2 plus 0 is 2
this 30 plus the 40 gets us to a 70. or
it's a 3 plus a 4 in the tens place and
then 400 plus 500 is 900 so we get to
972
and one more of these multiplications 25
times
25 times 15 and actually we could do
that in our head this is 26 times 15 so
25 times 15 is going to be this minus
15. so it's going to be 300 see if you
subtract 10 you get to 380 subtract
another five
375. let me do it in that same color so
plus
plus
375
and now let's add up these numbers so we
have 375
plus 972
plus 390
390
plus 400
plus
400
and so this gets us two
five and this is a home stretch we
deserve a drum roll now five plus two is
seven
seven plus seven is fourteen plus nine
is twenty three
two plus three is five plus nine is
fourteen
seventeen
so the square footage of this house 2
137 square
square
feet